So here, this is a really quite unusual sample
from Goodfellow and you
see this is samarium, so this is one of the
lanthanides.
Ok so samarium is a beautiful element to work
with as it can change
what we refer to as oxidation states very
easily which gives it many
more things it can do in chemistry. It’s
also a fascinating element in the
sense that we can use it to date samples from
the moon.
So this is a sample of samarium and there’s
is a very small amount of it
here, perhaps half of a gram. But you know
there's some interesting
things we can see about this package because
we can see on this label it
says “packed in argon – handle with care.”
Now it’s packed in argon
because argon is very, very inert, it doesn’t
react with anything, so it’s
used to store, safely, this sample so that
we can get it to carry out
research. But I think that this sample has
perhaps become damaged
because, I think, the packets maybe broken
because the samarium is
gone and all you can see there inside is this
white powder which, I
suspect, is samarium oxide, so unfortunately
not elemental samarium,
but close.
Samarium is also very important because it’s
a neutron absorber,
which means it’s got a lot of use in nuclear
power stations. Basically to
stop them going ‘boom’.